je m'appelle pas aux stands mais tu vas
pas les fumées pour pas parce que tu
vois j'ai vécu à l'air ça fait chier je
suis ici pour le casse tête oblige
établi qu'après avoir proposé ce qu'est
ce que vous faites dans ma chambre je
voulais seulement démontré à chambre la
plus belle de la direction j'apprenne
deux ans j'étais en soirée ont tous
secteurs
je le sens
lui dire elle a laissé une adresse d'une
agence pôle travaille à milan et je sais
prendre juste à attendre
rien de plus
je tenais à les produits
qui finance à dauphine à 10 c
côté touristes
non mais quoi
non
là je suis parti
ça bouge à louiseville
m
c'est bizarre on dirait que ça va mieux
pour moi parce que